we believe that he is in the court
building behind me here at Manchester
Crown Court but there has been a delay
of about half an hour or so we
understand that is now due to events and
that Thomas Cashman will now not appear
in court so that means he won't be in
there in person to hear either the
victim impact statements that are
expected to be read out on behalf and by
family members he won't hear the
arguments mitigating arguments both from
his defense team but also the
prosecution team that may then affect
the sentencing and crucially he won't be
there in person to hear the sentence
that he receives after being found
guilty last week of Olivia's murder and
further counts of attempted murder the
wounding of Olivia's mother Cheryl
Corbell and two Council possessing a
firearm that is quite an unusual turn of
events Olivia's family are here walking
into court today Olivia's mum said she
simply didn't really know how she felt
at the moment a big part of them
attending Court you might assume was to
be able to see Thomas Cashman as he's
sentenced for the murder of little
nine-year-old Olivia but they won't
receive that today unless perhaps during
that break between the victim impact
statements being read out and the judge
returning for sentencing maybe that
might change but we understand for now
that Thomas Cashman 34 years old will
not be in court in person to hear that
sentence being delivered
sentencing that we are expecting this
hour as you said it may go on until
after three o'clock depending on what's
happening in the courtroom there at
Manchester Crown Court worth reminding
viewers Katarina
how we got here today uh Thomas Cashman
found guilty on all counts on Thursday
last week including the count of murder
and remind us of those and what the
expected sentence will be today
well there are five charges that Thomas
Cashman was found guilty of the jury out
for a relatively short space of time in
the end about a day and a half of
deliberations after a three-week trial
here those five counts including the
murder of nine-year-old Olivia the
wounding of her mother Cheryl caulbell
the attempted murder of Joseph knee who
the prosecution argued was the intended
target of the initial attack by Thomas
Cashman and then to count the possession
of an illegal firearm now after being
found guilty of murder the mandatory
Life Center would be a mandatory life
sentence a minimum of 30 years and then
what will have been considered already
by the judge and will be further argued
in court today will be mitigating
factors by both sides both the
prosecution and the defense but I think
one thing that will be taken into
consideration is that Thomas Cashman
throughout this has not shown any
remorse certainly in court he has
vehemently denied all of the charges
against him so that might play a part in
determining the length of the sentence
that he receives here but it will be an
extremely significant moment this is a
case and and you've heard it from the
guests that you've spoken to over the
last 40 minutes or so Sarah Jane this is
a case that has shaken an entire
Community an entire city and it's
probably not overblown to say when the
news came out of the death of an
innocent child nine years old
in a ganglang related shooting it was a
story that shocked the entire country
and people will be watching they will be
noting now that Thomas Cashman has
decided not to appear in court to hear
himself being sentenced to hear
firsthand the impact from Olivia's
family that this has had on them and I
think it will be a very of course and
Incredibly difficult but significant day
for Olivia's family we have seen her
mother and her father arriving here in
court today Olivia Corbell walking in
clutching a pink teddy bear of Olivia's
many of the family members wearing pink
into court today as as they have
throughout the trial but also as they
did at her funeral last year I believe
you were working that day as I was and
remember hearing the eulogy of Olivia's
mother and how she described that she's
still couldn't say goodbye to her
daughter and she would just every night
in her head or out loud just say good
night and that is something that her
mother will carry with her and we are
expecting a fuller family statement
after this sentencing today Katarina
thank you Katarina vertotsi there
following events at Manchester Crown
Court the latest as you heard there
Thomas Cashman the man found guilty of
the murder of little Olivia refusing to
go into the courtroom for his sentencing
we're going to follow events inside the
courtroom closely here on Sky News we'll
bring you the sentencing live as and
when it gets underway Thomas Cashman
refusing to go to the courtroom has
caused a delay we'll bring you an update
as soon as we get it but here at Sky
News we have spoken to the chief
Constable of merseyside police
who told us that Olivia's murder should
be a defining moment for the region
absolutely delighted that Thomas Cashman
has been found guilty of the murder of
Olivia you know devastating for her
family
simply can't imagine the pain that
they've been going through since August
last year and I absolutely send my
heartfelt condolences to the family I
know the conviction today is not going
to bring Olivia back it's not going to
ease the pain of losing a daughter
bought some small comfort
person who snuffed out the life of
Olivia far too early is now facing a
life sentence Behind Bars our describe
him as a coward despicable
he
decided on that night
or decided in the days beforehand to
play out a petty dispute using guns on
the streets of merseyside in the
community of dovecott and that has had a
devastating impact for Olivia's family
which we they will live with for the
rest of their lives
every waking moment and every moment
they go to sleep
he made great play in the in the trial
that he is a dad
and yet he's put Olivia's family through
this trial I hope he reflects every
morning when he wakes up behind bars and
every night when he goes to sleep about
what he's put Olivia's family through a
cowardly criminal who decides to take
the law into his own hands and settle
Petty disputes by using two by using two
firearms anybody who does that they're
not thinking about the consequences they
don't care about anybody who lives in
their communities he was just intent in
settling what was a petty dispute and
the consequences for Olivia's family are
devastating do
culture and organized crime in Liverpool
I absolutely do but I recognize that
that is on the back of this year where
we've had five people who've been killed
in in firearms in Firearms murders but
merseyside is recognized by hmic FRS as
outstanding in our approach to tackling
serious and organized crime we've got
really strong teams in place to tackle
Firearms crime we have seen in
merseyside we are at the lowest number
of firearms discharges that we've seen
in 20 in 20 years you know in 2012 we
saw 125 Firearms discharges in 2021 that
number was down at 39 so we are taking a
positive and successful approach to
tackling gun crime on the streets of
merseyside likewise with our approach to
serious and organized crime but I say
that when five people have lost their
lives and to me that is you know the
time to renew our commitment to working
with our partners and we're working with
our communities together to make sure
that those offenders can't operate here
in merseyside
while we continue to wait for the
sentencing of Thomas Cashman here on Sky
News there has been a delay because
Thomas Cashman wishes to be sentenced in
his absence he is refusing to enter the
courtroom to hear his sentencing and
hear the victim impact statements from
Olivia Pratt corbell's Family we've got
some more detail on this and author of
England correspondent Katarina vitotsi
is standing by outside Manchester Crown
Court and there's some interesting
detail coming out from inside the
courtroom Katarina
yes in the last few minutes the defense
Barrister for Thomas Cashman who's John
Cooper KC's explained to the judge Mrs
Justice yet why Cashman Thomas Cashman
decided not to come into the courtroom
although he is in the building behind me
Manchester Crown Court and uh John
Cooper Casey saying that Mr Cashman was
aware that the CPS has the crown
prosecution service was singing We are
the champions in the corridors following
the guilty verdict in his trial on
Thursday
um
Mr Cooper going on to say that Mr
Catherine has been spoken to and given
certain advice but that he missed
referring to Mr Cashman is concerned
that the matter is turning into a circus
and it's for that reason he has not come
into the courtroom
um Mrs Justice Yips said in reference to
that though that yes she understood that
that may have been a sequence of events
but regarded Mr cashman's decision not
to attend courtroom as disrespectful not
only to the court but those interested
in the proceedings including the family
of the deceased so just to remind you
that we were expecting Thomas Cashman in
court today to hear Victim Impact
statements to hear legal arguments
regarding his sentencing but also to
hear his sentencing after being found
guilty of those five charges last week
including the murder of nine-year-old
Olivia Pratt Corbell but as you can hear
they're the reasons that he is decided
not to attend or not to come into the
courtroom in person after saying that he
heard that the CPS the crown prosecution
service was singing We Are the Champions
uh following a guilty verdict in his
trial on Thursday
we understand that everyone else with a
part to play in the sentencing is inside
the courtroom no members of Thomas
cashman's family are present in the
courtroom he also looks to be absent as
well and Katarina it's worth reminding
people who may just be joining us here
on Sky News the sentence that is
expected uh the court Duty bound to
impose a sentence of life imprisonment
yes and typically there would be a
minimum of 30 years for a sentence of
that gravity what we will hear today in
the course of the legal argument will be
whether there are aggravating
circumstances for that to be either
longer or shorter there are five charges
that he will be sentenced on today we
are likely to hear if they will be run
concurrently but the murder of
nine-year-old Olivia Pratt Corbell would
be the one that you would imagine would
incur at the longest sentence a minimum
of 30 years typically as I said and for
Olivia's family today this would have
been the last opportunity probably for
them to see Thomas Cashman in a
courtroom they've arrived here today
we've seen Olivia's mum Cheryl walking
in clutching a pink teddy bear one of
Olivia's favorite toys we've seen
Olivia's father we've seen other family
members all coming in as they have done
over the past three weeks of this trial
but they will not see Thomas Cashman in
the doctor today unless something
massively significant changes but it
seems unlikely and Mr Justice yet
confirming that she will go ahead with
the sentencing in his absence Thomas
Cashman making that decision not to
enter court today of course our viewers
might remember that over the course of
this trial he is vehemently denied that
he had any part to play in this shooting
he said he was not the gunman he said he
did not try to murder Joseph Lee who the
prosecution argued was the intended
victim of this attack that he did not
ruin Cheryl that he did quite simply not
pull the trigger he has shown No Remorse
within the courtroom although at times
he was seen to be brushing away tears
where people describe the sequence of
events that led to Olivia Pratt Corbell
being shot in the chest that night but
no remorse no at any point of course he
said he was not guilty for all these
charges and today a refusal for him to
appear in person in court to hear
that is breaking news as we wait for
Thomas Cashman to be sentenced for the
murder of nine-year-old Olivia Pratt
Corbell in Liverpool Thomas Cashman has
told his Council which has in turn told
the judge that he would not be appearing
in the court dock this afternoon to hear
his sentence and as Katarina was saying
there nor to hear the Family Impact
statements um let's just remind viewers
of the details of the case that has led
us to the sentencing today uh we can
bring you footage now of cashman's
arrest it was released after he was
found guilty of murdering Olivia the
video shows Catherine being surrounded
by armed officers on the 4th of
September last year
we're almost done
[Music]
put your knees up he's up to your chest
sit on your ass
stand up
did you say to yourself
I just want to know what I've done
that's all
foreign
whatsoever
Thomas Cashman they're being arrested by
police it's worth it reminding you of
what's going on in Manchester Crown
Court right now there's been a slight
delay to the sentencing of Thomas
Catherine because he is refusing uh to
be inside that courtroom uh when the
sentence is handed down by the judge Mrs
Justice Yip
um the sentencing will be brought to you
live here on Sky News but the judge um
is um going to deliver her sentencing
remarks which we can bring you live this
is after the prosecution and the defense
have addressed the court that is
underway now standing by our north of
England correspondent Katarina vertotsi
and Katarina remind us of the
investigation that led to that moment we
saw there and the arrest of Thomas
Cashman
well the murder of little nine-year-old
Olivia sparked one of the most intense
and even the officers involved would
admit difficult investigations in
merseyside police's history they talked
about
combing hours and hours and hours of CCT
at CCTV evidence and you got a sense of
that in the case that was presented here
at Manchester Crown Court over the past
three weeks
moments and minutes and seconds leading
up to the gunman chasing Joseph knee
down the street and then firing that
shot into the house of Cheryl and Olivia
from Pratt Corbell that that in the end
ultimately killed Olivia moments of
these footage which showed Thomas
cashman's movement on that day were
painstakingly presented in court to
build a picture that the prosecution
said was so compelling that showed
Thomas Cashman to be in the right place
at the right time that they felt it just
brought a body of evidence that simply
couldn't be couldn't then in the end
result in any other verdict other than a
guilty verdict in terms of all the
charges presented towards him
it has been an extremely difficult
investigation as I say for merseyside
police we've heard interviews just in
the last few hours with officers who
were involved in it and and really
expressing how it was that this was a
case that involved a child who was
ultimately entirely innocent a family
whose lives have been changed forever
caught up in a cycle of drug-based gang
violence that has affected not only
their family but our entire Community
who were
scared and frightened by what happened
and many of them feeling too frightened
to come forward and speak we actually
know that that merseyside police at
times had to use legal proceedings to
get people to release CCTV footage of
what was happening outside their
properties on that evening such was that
fear of the gang-related environment
that there is in parts of merseyside and
continues to be in parts of merseyside
and Olivia Pratt corbell's Family
showing immense strength and immense
courage coming into court every day but
also crucially for the prosecution and
for the police investigation was the
witness statement from
really the main prosecution witness a
woman who is now in witness protection
whose identity was not revealed in court
but who was the woman who said that
Thomas Cashman on that night after
Olivia had been shot dead that Thomas
Cashman came into her house woke her up
seeming agitated asking for clean
clothes and then overhearing a
conversation within which he said I've
done Joey and the police saying that it
was an immense Act of Bravery for that
woman to come forward given the context
that I've just outlined and it was an
enormous police investigation and one
that has resulted in Thomas cash was
being found relatively quickly by the
jury one and a half days or so
deliberation guilty of all five charges
against him the murder of Olivia
nine-year-old Olivia the wounding of her
mother Cheryl the attempted murder of
Joseph knee the intended target of this
attack and then two counts of possession
of an illegal firearm and I think it's
worth just reminding people that Thomas
Cashman won't appear in court today he's
made that decision his defense council's
telling the judge it was because he
heard that the CPS the crown prosecution
service had been singing We are the
champions in the corridors after the
guilty verdict was received on Thursday
Mr Cash was saying he was concerned
things were turning into a circus but
Mrs Mrs Justice yet saying that whether
or not that was true that was still not
a sufficient reason for him not to be in
court to hear his sentencing call it
disrespectful not only towards the court
but also towards Olivia's family and
confirming that she will sentence him
even if he's not here there to hear it
in person
here we are waiting to bring you the
sentencing remarks of the judge live
here on Sky News as soon as they get
underway we are hearing at the moment uh
picked in personal impact statements
inside the courtroom Olivia's father has
been
um well the legal team for Olivia's
family have been reading out John
Pratt's victim personal statement he has
said that
um I've been asked to do the impossible
and put into words how the murder of my
beautiful daughter has affected me no
words can make you understand the pain I
am feeling my heart
sorry beg your pardon and she would
never be given the opportunity to fall
in love and have her own children I
would never get the opportunity to see
my daughter on her wedding day most of
all I'll never get to see her grow into
the beautiful woman she was destined to
become we have been robbed of her future
and the amazing teenager and adult she
was destined to become she will forever
be nine
it's three o'clock you're watching Sky
News we are waiting uh for the
sentencing of Thomas Cashman uh live
here on the program uh the man found
guilty last week for the murder of the
young girl you're seeing on your screen
there nine-year-old Olivia Pratt Corbell
it's been confirmed uh within the last
15 to 20 minutes that 34 year old Thomas
Cashman will not be in court for
sentencing he is going to receive a life
sentence for the murder of young Olivia
this is after he chased a rival into her
home in Liverpool last August he is a
drug dealer he traced a rival in to the
home of young Olivia Pratt called Bell
uh it was a crime that shocked the
country well Olivia's mom arrived at
court a short while ago
Cheryl can you discuss how are you
feeling
it's a really no
for words for anyone not connected with
this crime how we feel today for
Olivia's Mom it is impossible let's just
bring you some more of the the victim
statement from Olivia's Father John
Pratt that's been read out in the last
few moments these are all done away from
TV cameras the sentencing remarks from
the judge we will bring to you live
um but John Pratt saying no words can
make you understand the pain that I am
feeling my heart has been forever broken
by your actions these of course the
words of Olivia's father that he had
hoped to say to Thomas Cashman directly
but of course he has chosen not to
appear inside that courtroom today Mr
Pratt goes on to say you took the
decision to shoot into Olivia's home
with no regard to who was there I want
you to know you have changed my life
forever we will never be a whole family
again you did that to us
uh Mr Pratt said that he moved away from
Liverpool for a period and he said it
was a constant reminder of the loss of
my beautiful daughter we lost precious
time due to the covert pandemic but we
always saw Olivia
as much as we could little did I know
that was the day before her death the
last time I saw her
um the victim statements impact
statements being read out in court right
now and we were bringing more of those
as they are read out we will bring you
the sentencing remarks uh from the judge
Justice Yip live here on Sky News as
soon as that gets underway let's bring
in our north of England correspondent
Katarina vitotsi who's outside
Manchester Crown Court for us and
Katarina there has been a delay uh in
the sentencing because of Thomas
cashman's refusal to enter the courtroom
um but the proceedings are carrying on
and we're just into those deeply
personal Family Impact statements which
is a chance for them to say
exactly what Thomas cashman's actions
have done to their family
yes and I think there would have been an
expectation certainly amongst the family
members who are here that those
statements would have been heard in
person by Thomas Cashman but as you say
he has taken the decision not to come
into the courtroom today although he is
in the court building managed the Crown
Court behind me and we understand that
is uh because of a reason given by his
defense Barrister to the judge that Mr
Cashman heard that after the guilty
verdict on Thursday that the crown
prosecution service or members of the
crown prosecution service was singing We
Are the Champions and due to that Mr
Cashman says that he felt things were
turning into a circus and for that
reason he has decided not to come into
the courtroom today Mrs Justice Yip
saying that she's felt that actually was
incredibly disrespectful not only to the
court but of course also to the family
of Bolivia that he has decided to do
that but she will continue the sentence
thing without him but it also does mean
of course that these Victims Impact
statements we've already heard one read
out on behalf of Olivia's father
um it means that Thomas Cashman will not
hear those first hand and hear
heartbreak within those words and in the
last few minutes
Olivia's older sister Chloe has actually
read out herself her own Victim Impact
statement moving into the witness box
to recount
her thoughts feelings what happened and
what changed in that moment on August
22nd 2022 she says that day was the
worst day of my life not only did I lose
my baby sister but I lost my best friend
I felt as though my heart had stopped
beating a piece of me left that night
and since then I felt as though I'm in a
nightmare and I cannot wake up my family
and I are living in a real life tragedy
this is all because of selfish people
thinking it's okay to carry guns and
putting innocent people at risk I miss
my baby sister I miss my best friend I
miss sharing my bedroom with her and
hearing her talk all the time I'm beyond
grateful to have had nine years of
Olivia I will keep those memories
forever
those words read out in person by Olivia
Pratt corbell's older sister Chloe who
has been here pretty consistently over
the past three weeks Olivia's mum Cheryl
being here every single day coming in
today as she did on Thursday clutching a
pink teddy bear one of Olivia's favorite
toys in one of her favorite colors and
it is a color that members of Olivia's
family have been wearing as they've come
to court it's a color we saw people
wearing on the day of her funeral and
Olivia
her mum today
oh in fact we've just had
Olivia's mums Cheryl's Victim Impact
statement if we have time I'll just read
that to you now again as I said stepping
in to the witness box carrying that pink
teddy bear she says the bear is made out
of Olivia's pajamas and now it sleeps
with her in her bed and she talks at the
moment Olivia was born prematurely
weighing just over four pounds saying
she was so tiny she fit in one hand
and she talks and recounts of the years
of seeing Olivia grow up She says I
couldn't believe my baby was going into
big school she loved helping others she
had a special bond with one of her
teachers she was such a social butterfly
she was particularly good with younger
children she was such a caring little
girl and she goes on to recount these
special moments that she had with her
daughter for nine years far too many
losing her in such a tragic way and and
that Victim Impact statement of Gerald
Corbell Olivia's mum still ongoing in
court right now and as I said Thomas
Cashman will not be there in person in
court to hear the impact of
his actions that night the impact it had
he's made that decision not to go into
the courtroom and confirmation from Mrs
Justice yet that he will be sentenced in
his absence after making that decision
not to come into the courtroom today
those Family Impact statements are being
read out in court after that comes a
sentencing Justice Yip will be
delivering her sentencing remarks we can
bring that to you live here on Sky News
in the meantime we can bring you some of
those impact statements difficult for
Katarina I to read out and you can only
imagine what it's like for family
members to have to say these words in
the courtroom without being able to say
them to Thomas Cashman the man who
murdered their little Olivia he has
refused to go into the courtroom today
he has protested his innocence
throughout this trial but he has been
found guilty and will be sentenced today
for the murder of Olivia Pratt Corbell
Olivia's dad John Pratt the legal team
read out his victim personal statement
and he said that Olivia will be forever
nine
and will never call me dad again he said
I've been asked to do the impossible and
put into words how the murder of my
beautiful daughter has affected me no
words can make you understand the pain I
am feeling he talked about sitting
outside the cemetery
because it was too painful to go inside
because that would make Olivia's death
real the statement directly addressed
Thomas Cashman but of course Thomas
Cashman not there I leave his dad said
you took the decision to shoot into
Olivia's home with no regard to who was
there I want you to know you have
changed my life forever we will never be
a whole family again you did that to us
Mr Pratt said he has nightmares about
how Olivia died every day those
nightmares remind me of Olivia and what
I have lost those four girls and my two
older daughters are the only reason I'm
still here every day I feel completely
overwhelmed and I don't know how I'll
cope uh Katarina you know us to reading
out those statements because we can't
bring them to viewers here live on Sky
News it's difficult but it's just a
reminder of how important family
statements are in court it's their
chance
to speak you know if you're not giving
evidence in a trial that's a chance for
them to tell the court to tell the
person that's committed that crime to
tell the world exactly how they feel and
what Justice Means to them
you are absolutely right in that the
past three weeks Olivia's family members
have sat in the public Gallery they've
listened to witness testimony they've
seen the pieces of CCTV they've watched
Thomas Cashman they saw his uh defense
and all his statements and this as you
say is their chance if they're not
called as a witness themselves their
chance for their voices to be heard in
court and I'll just read you a little
bit more of the statement that's being
made by Cheryl Corbell reading this not
via
the prosecution team but herself in her
own voice these are her words and she
would have expected today to be able to
deliver them directly to Thomas Cashman
but he has made the decision not to go
into the courtroom not to hear these
Victim Impact statements and not to hear
sentencing in person just a reminder
that that decision was made according to
his defense team by Mr Cashman after he
heard the crown prosecution service
singing We Are the Champions After the
the verdicts were delivered on Thursday
his defense team saying that Mr Cashman
was concerned things were turning into a
circus now so deciding not to come into
the courtroom to hear the sentencing
today Mr Justice Yip saying though she
in her view felt like it was extremely
disrespectful for him not to come in
disrespectful boats to the court but of
course to Olivia's family who were there
now having those victim impacts
statements read out either on their
behalf or by themselves directly
um
Olivia's mum Cheryl her victim in
statement is still ongoing now the first
few minutes of it was her just
remembering what it was like from the
moment that a little Olivia her youngest
child was born to the moment that that
trigger was pulled on August 22nd last
year and she died
totally an innocent bystander
and this cobal continues in this Victim
Impact statement
sorry do you
Katarina you have it there I was just
going to say there is more information
coming out as to to what Olivia's mom
Cheryl would say we saw her there
clutching that teddy bear that she
described as as being made from Olivia's
pajamas so that she could take her to
bed with her every night and she does
continue her Victim Impact statement
we've got more of it that you can bring
us Katarina
um
yeah she describes what it's like now
being in the home in her home without
Olivia there she describes Olivia who
she calls live live never stopped
talking she would be chatting away one
thing I miss most is hearing her say mum
I just miss hearing her voice it's just
so quiet I would do anything to have her
chatting to me it's so lonely without
her everything is so quiet I can't cope
with the silence setting my alarm at 7
30 in the morning as something ingrained
in me the day goes by in a blur it gets
to half two and I think about the school
pickup something I will never do again
she will always be my baby tea time is a
big thing for me it was so centered
around her and what she wanted for tea
everything I do is a constant reminder
that she is not there with me this
happened in our home where we should
have been safe we have no choice to
leave lives first and only home when we
were allowed back it was utter
heartbreak it was as though time had
Stood Still The Cups of Tea on the table
next to her princess trust form one of
her dolls lay on the floor in that
moment I was home we were back to how
our lives were before that night I
soaked up the surroundings until reality
dawned and brought me back to our living
nightmare
it's
heartbreaking to hear those feelings so
condensed into these Victim Impact
statements and Cheryl Corbell continues
to say in this statement packing up our
home was horrendous packing clothes her
toys packing my baby's things into a box
no mother should ever have to do that we
left our friends our neighbors it's so
hard to go back to the area I grew up in
and raise my children the smallest
things remind me of Liv her friends
playing in the street it's hard to
accept she is no longer here
Olivia's mum continues the night I
realized Liv had been shot I was not
able to do CPR probably because of my
injury remember she was shot in the
wrist by the same bullet that passed
through her front door passed through
her wrist injuring her and that was the
same bullet that then hit Olivia in the
chest
she says I did not have full use of my
hand and I felt helpless my neighbor
tried all he could to save my baby my
worst nightmare was being separated from
Liv and not being there when she needed
me most I cannot get my head around how
Cashman continued to shoot after hearing
the terrifying screams the utter
Devastation he has caused he doesn't
care how could he
those words directed from Olivia's
mother Cheryl to Thomas Cashman who she
would have expected to be in the
courtroom to hear them in person but he
has decided not to be in the courtroom
today for for reasons I've described not
there in person to hear the words the
impact that his actions has had and
devastating a family and leading to the
death of an innocent nine-year-old girl
Katarina thank you yes um We are
continuing to hear Family Impact
statements Katarina just remind us of
the sentencing that's going to happen
today what we could expect
or Thomas Cashman on Thursday was found
guilty of five charges won the murder of
nine-year-old Olivia the attempted
murder of Joseph knee who the
prosecution say was the intended target
of his attack the wounding of Olivia's
mother Cheryl as I described there she
talks about being wounded in the wrist
and hand and unable to use that then to
provide CPR to her daughter as she live
bleeding in the corridor and then
further two charges of the possession of
an illegal firearm now the the guilty
verdict and respect to the charge of
murder against Olivia would mean a
mandatory life sentence with a minimum
term of around 30 years what we're
expecting to hear is further legal
argument there will be then
deliberations by the judge who has taken
her time with this sentencing the guilty
verdict came back on Thursday but Mrs
Justice ship saying she would take
time to consider the sentencing not
coming back on Friday but waiting until
after the weekend to return that verdict
we'll also hear
whether these sentences will run
concurrently there will undoubtedly be
within the sentencing consideration of
the fact that Thomas Cashman pleaded not
guilty he denied all these charges
vehemently throughout this three-week
trial he went into the witness stand and
said I was not the gunman I did not do
it he showed no remorse for what had
happened to that will factor in no doubt
to the sentencing that we're expecting
today after these Victim Impact
statements are concluded we would then
expect a short pause while the judge
retires to consider further her
sentencing before then that is as
delivered and that is something that
sentencing remarks that we will be able
to bring you live for now the victim
impact statements continue to be read
out in court No cameras allowed at this
point but we can report what is being
said and it is important to hear what is
being said because this as you say is
one of the first opportunities that many
members of Olivia Pratt corbell's family
will have to
address Thomas Cashman or at least have
now their words conveyed to him given
that he's now decided not to be in the
courtroom and we've got some further in
detail of the victim impact statement of
Olivia's mother Cheryl who says directly
about Thomas Cashman that his actions
have left the biggest hole in our lives
that can never be filled that man set
out to do a job and he didn't care about
anyone else who got in the way he
certainly couldn't own it either Ryan
Chloe those are Olivia's brother and
sister and I are just existing day to
day we have been waiting for the trial
and not addressing how broken we are as
a family I can't think about rebuilding
our lives without her we've missed out
on so much my nan who was 92 adored live
and live her recently her health
deteriorated and she was admitted to
hospital due to being at court every day
we've not been able to spend enough
quality time with her and I believe she
held on long enough to hear that coward
had been found guilty sadly my nan
passed away last night
this Farm live
enjoyed such incredible heartbreak
my nine-year-old Liv was the light of
Our Lives she was a character she was my
baby she had amazing qualities and knew
what she wanted in life she will never
get to wear a prom dress have a sweet
16th birthday walk down the aisle or
become a mother and have children of her
own all that promise for her future so
cruelly taken away now I have to drive
to the cemetery to be close to my baby
daughter
I miss her smile her kisses her cuddles
she will always be with me my little
Shadow we love you endless amounts and
those are the last words in Cheryl
corebells Victim Impact statement she
subscribed in being in the court in the
in the courtroom in the court just
behind me of returning to her seat still
clutching that teddy bear made as she
described from Olivia's pajamas that now
she keeps with her in bed every night
her little Shadow as she describes her
oh Katarina thank you so much for
reading that out um difficult to hear I
mean how Olivia's mum got up there and
read out those words and kept her
composure
you know it's just incredible the
strength that that family have found
particularly as we heard there a
relative passed away last night but they
found comfort in the fact that
um
Cheryl corbell's Nan um was around long
enough to find that Thomas Cashman had
been found guilty of little Olivia's
murder we are expecting those sentencing
remarks any moment now uh we'll bring
them to you live here on Sky News
justice it will deliver those uh now
that those impact statements have been
read out while we wait for that let's
speak to Chantal Lunt she is a former
police officer at merseyside police
um Chantelle thank you for so much for
joining us this afternoon
difficult for us to hear I mean you
can't even imagine what it's like to be
inside that courtroom and be part of
that family that's dealing with this
right now
no it's just it's absolutely hard but
you can just listening to that Victim
Impact statement by him Cheryl Corbell
it's just
the lives have been destroyed and you
know the fact the farmers caution didn't
even saying obstacle to hear from his
actions have had just really speaks to
that indifference and well
just my heart goes off to the family
it's absolutely devastating
um and just really get you there I think
as a mother as well you know as a mother
of an eight-year-old just all of those
things was a little one being a shadow
really really just heartbreaking and
she's so brave Shadow for stands and up
in court and be announcer around
statement too
when she said she would never be called
mum Again by Olivia and just the silence
the silence there's so much noise you
know created by a a nine-year-old as a
mother you know those are the simple
things that
that will haunt her and that's what she
laid bare there there in the courtroom
Thomas Cashman as we've been explaining
to our viewers not in the courtroom
today uh to hear his sentence uh nor
hear those Family Impact statements that
are either read out
um by parts of the legal team or by
members of the family themselves if they
feel up to doing so Olivia's sister and
mother have stood up to to read out
their statements uh in their own words
and Chantelle difficult so difficult for
the family I mean I can't even find a
word to describe what they're going
through but difficult for merseyside
police as well in terms of the pressure
they were under they will have felt this
personally as well in terms of you know
look at little Olivia there that's you
know one of their own in Liverpool this
was a community that came together to
deliver Justice for her
yeah yeah I mean I think just the whole
city felt it really and and as you know
the victim impact statement has shown
it's just especially appearance it says
if you're on that level and really
struck into that
it because it happens in the home
there's just this idea that you don't
feel that anywhere is safe so I think
that when the police have investigated
that would really be at the Forefront of
their mind they really needs to find
this person who needs to leave no stone
unturned away with the community to find
the major and also to reassure the
community in terms of their response to
you know in gang activity in the region
as a whole so um it's good that he's
been brought to Justice it's called the
the sentence and it's happening today
because there's no bringing Olivia back
and in all that we can hope is that the
sentence reflects the devastation that
has been causing to the family and The
Wider Community through his actions
uh Chantelle the final question for you
um what impact would this have
on the gangs in Liverpool the drug wars
as it's been called you know looking at
little Olivia's face there we have been
here before
um you know not just in Liverpool but up
and down the country and we talk about
Watership moments this has to be the
moment that things change what's your
view on that do you are you optimistic
with regard to that
and I think I know as you touched upon
it's an issue that's in Country-Wide and
it's often happens in areas in working
class areas where there's a lot of
marginalization I think for me you've
touched upon again there's been children
you know they've been children like
Reese Jones last year there was in a 14
year old school girl and the people who
shot on the neck in the crossfire and
what often happens is these gang wars
spill out onto the streets and you know
children and innocent bystanders get
caught in the crossfire years ago it was
you know you've already really heard of
shootings happening in the daytime now
they're happening in the daytime while
you know kids who were going to school
or else on the streets and that actually
happening in the one safe space the
children have the homes so I think it
shook the community to the core but in
relation to
gangs and criminal activity I hope that
the sentence really does reflect the cry
and it's enough to make people consider
what the consequences of their actions
are because if we look at what's
happening in court within Thomas Cashman
there doesn't seem to be any remorse
that doesn't seem to be any reflection
on what it was actions have done and how
the devastated the family there just
seems to be
um basically it'll be the solidity of
the sentence that really might make them
sit up and look and take account of what
has happened but I think this is a
moment for the wiser Community for the
police force to really sit up and look
and have a look at where we are and
again not just in Liverpool not just
amazing side but in the wiser UK because
this is you know the prevalence of gangs
of very much a reflection of the
economic instability that we're facing
of the recessions of marginalized
communities and and young menly we're
getting younger and younger and younger
being recruited into these gangs because
they don't see another way and I think
we need not just the boss's place funds
not just the police rebuilding those
links of the community so that they know
what is happening so that they know what
gang activity is happening but we also
need Services we need financial
investments in communities so that young
men are just walking into the arms of
drug dealers but into you know into
rooms whether it be an interview for
jobs into rooms whether it be an
interview for positions in Academia
because it's lack of opportunities and
absolute under funds and Liverpool's got
some of the most surprised areas in the
country and that's where you see this
gang culture that's where you see this
prevalence and it's reflected into part
there is all over the UK but I think we
need to use this as a watershed movement
not only to look at what's happening but
look at the response to what's happening
and it needs to be a holistic response
that isn't just on the police but is on
all factors of Public Services which
includes massive reinvestments and a
massive rebuilding of trust within
communities
um Chantelle Lunt uh thank you so much
for joining us this afternoon while we
await the set to sing remarks from
Justice Yip at Manchester Crown Court
the sentencing of Thomas Cashman for the
murder of Olivia Pratt called Bell due
shortly Chantelle Lund former police
officer and merseyside police it's worth
reminding viewers why Thomas Cashman
isn't appearing in court today does
cause a delay to proceedings um his
legal counsel have told the judge that
he is not appearing in court personally
because the crown prosecution service
members of the crown prosecution service
sang We Are The Champions
following the verdict in his trial the
judge Mrs Justice yipin response said
she regarded his lack of attendance as
disrespectful to not only the court but
those interested in proceedings
including the family of Olivia with the
family of Olivia have been brave once
again on her behalf today they have read
out those personal Family Impact
statements to the courtroom they had
hoped that Thomas Cashman would be there
to hear them directly however he is not
in court
um Olivia Pratt corbell's Father John
Pratt he had his statement read out on
his behalf he said I want you to know
that you have changed my life and my
family's life forever I have nightmares
about how she died and the nightmares
won't go away I am heartbroken sometimes
I just want to end it so that I can be
with Olivia again I want to visit Olivia
and I sometimes sit outside the cemetery
but I can't go in it because if I do it
will all seem too real Mr Pratt was in
court
sitting watching his statement be read
out the statement went on to say you
have denied my beautiful girl Olivia her
future I will never see her on her
wedding day and walk her down the aisle
and see her grow into the beautiful
woman she was destined to become we have
been robbed of her future because of you
she will always be forever nine
Olivia's sister her older sister stood
up in court earlier to read her
statement herself she spoke from the
witness box uh her sister is Chloe
Corbell she said this Olivia was the
best friend I had always wanted we were
so close as I was not only her big
sister but I'd look after her when our
mum was working
Olivia believed what was mine was also
hers I'd often look for something and
not be able to find it it'd turn up the
next day in her makeup bag or in one of
her drawers
Chloe said the day Olivia was killed was
the worst of her life she said not only
did I lose my baby sister but I lost my
best friend
when I was told he had passed away I
felt as though my heart stopped beating
Chloe said she and her family are living
in a real life tragedy because of
selfish people thinking it's okay to
carry guns
Chloe Corbell went on to say I miss my
baby sister and I miss my best friend
all the things we should be doing
shopping together laughing together and
making memories of Chloe called Bell
just a teenager standing up in that
witness box this afternoon to deliver
that statement on behalf of herself her
family and her little sister Olivia
well Olivia's mom Cheryl Corbell stood
up and read out her statement as well
she said that her nine-year-old was
loved by everyone and never stopped
talking
um Cheryl Corbell in tears as she
explained that Olivia was due to cut her
hair to donate it to sick children but
was killed just five days before her
appointment uh Cheryl Corbell says I
just miss hearing her voice I would give
anything in the world to have her
chatting to me Cheryl explained how the
alarm goes off in their house at 7 30 in
the morning every day it's the time that
she used to get up with Olivia and the
day then goes by in a blur by 2 30. she
says she is conditioned to be going on
the school run but that is something she
says she will never be able to do again
a cherical bell saying this happened in
our home where we felt safe she added
that they were allowed to return to the
house after the police investigation and
it was like time Stood Still
Jericho bell saying I was not able to do
CPR
on Olivia because of my injury you may
remember that the bullet that fatally
wounded young Olivia first went through
the wrist of her mother
um Cheryl Corbell saying I wasn't able
to do CPR because of that injury I felt
helpless my worst nightmare was being
separated from live and not being with
her when she needed me the most I cannot
get my head around how cashmen continued
to shoot after he heard the screams that
man set out to do a job and he didn't
care about anyone else or who got in the
way
Olivia's mom saying it is so hard to go
back to the area where she grew up and
where she raised her three children
they've moved into a new house which she
said was difficult for the whole family
I cannot even think about rebuilding our
lives without her she said
she went on to explain that while the
trial has been on her Nan was admitted
to hospital and she passed away last
night
Cheryl Corbell saying that she believed
her Nan was holding on to hear that
Thomas Cashman had been found guilty
she went on to describe Olivia as her
Shadow and ended her statement by saying
her family will love her endlessly
let's bring in our north of England
correspondent Katarina vatotsi who is at
Manchester Crown Court Katarina the
Family Impact statements have now been
read out in court and the legal
proceedings from both legal teams have
finished so it could be any time now
within the next few minutes that we'll
hear at the judge's sentencing remarks
live here on Sky News
yeah Mrs Justice Yip has temporarily
left the courtroom she will take a few
minutes we understand and then come back
to deliver her sentence remember it's
not just the charge of Olivia's murder
that Thomas Cashman was found guilty of
last week there's also the attempted
murder of Joseph Lee at the wounding of
Olivia's mum Cheryl corbellus as you
outlined they're injured in the wrist by
the same bullet that would then pass
through her and then hit her daughter in
the middle of the chest that one shot
that was fatal and then also further two
counts of possessions of an illegal
firearm Thomas Cashman though not in
court today although he came to
Manchester Crown Court he refused to
enter the courtroom he has not heard the
victim impact statements he's not heard
the legal arguments and he will not be
there in person to hear the sentencing
when it is delivered and it's worth
reminding
um viewers who may have just joined us
that he says the reason for that is
because he understands or he heard that
after the guilty verdicts were received
on Thursday that members of the crown
prosecution service were heard singing
We Are the Champions and Mr cashman's
defense say that their client Thomas
Cashman felt like things were turning
into a circus and it's for those reasons
he decided not to enter the courtroom Mr
Justice yet though saying that she felt
it was deeply disrespectful for him not
to be in court not just disrespectful to
the court but perhaps much more
pertinently and crucially for Olivia's
family who have been either having had
Victim Impact statements read out on
their behalf or going into the witness
box where they've seen Thomas Cashman
give evidence they've seen many people
give evidence but this is their turn to
be heard to have their statements for
them to be able to read out their own
statements and describe their heartbreak
statement from Olivia's older sister
Chloe and her mom Cheryl read out in
Manchester Crown Court courtroom behind
me just a few minutes ago what can we
expect from the sentencing well
the murder of Olivia Pratt called Bell
will mean a mandatory life sentence but
the discussion now will be looking at
what the minimum term that Thomas
Cashman will have to serve about a
minimum term typically 30 years there
will be now consideration of whether he
showed any remorse certainly in the
courtroom he didn't he vehemently denied
all of the charges against him over the
course of the past three weeks all of
the charges including that of a
murdering Olivia he said he wasn't the
intended he wasn't the gunman he never
intended to attack Joseph and he said he
wasn't even there but the jury here last
week taking about a day and a half after
three weeks of of testimony and witness
statement prosecution defense argument
finding him guilty of all those charges
against him that sentencing now expected
just in the next few minutes or so and
we will be able to bring you those
sentencing remarks in the sentencing
live via cameras that have been placed
here at Manchester Crown Court those
Victim Impact statements though
happening with cameras off although we
have been able to to hear and Report the
detail of them and the Heartbreak that
the family of Olivia Pratt Corbell have
suffered over the past few months since
she died on August the 22nd last year of
how their lives would change utterly and
how it continues to be a nightmare those
feelings felt so clearly in those
statements read out by Olivia's family
members and that statement read out on
behalf of Olivia's father as well so the
sentencing now expected just in the next
few I'm just going to interrupt you
because we're going to cross live now to
inside Manchester Crown Court the
sentencing of Thomas Cashman for the
murder of Olivia Pratt or Bell a warning
we're expecting the sentencing judge Mrs
Justice Yip set out the details of
Olivia's death so we may we have to warn
you this may be distressing has refused
to come themselves to be sentenced
I have directed that he should do so but
he has maintained his refusal
I am therefore left with no choice but
to sentence him in his absence
these sentencing remarks will be made
available to him in writing
all five offenses arise out of the
events of the 22nd of August 2022.
when armed with two guns the defendant
set out to kill Joseph knee
he lay in wait before opening fire in a
residential street
CCTV footage captured him standing over
Mr knee shooting at close range
when the first gun malfunctioned Mr knee
was able to scramble away
but the defendant had his second gun
ready
he relentlessly pursued Mr knee causing
him to seek Refuge by barging into the
home occupied by Olivia's family
undeterred and wholly unconcerned for
the safety of others he continued to
shoot at Joseph knee
firing into that family home
Olivia just nine years old heard the
commotion from her bed
unsurprisingly she came downstairs to
seek the comfort of her mother
her last words were mum I'm scared
in a terrible twist of fate she had
stepped directly into the line of fire
as her mother battled to keep the front
door closed the defendant fired a shot
that passed straight through the door
then through Cheryl corbell's wrist
and into Olivia's chest killing her
the defendant then managed to get his
hand inside the door and fired another
shot inside the house
fortunately the door was closed on his
hand and the bullet discharged into the
door frame avoiding the people inside
for the murder of Olivia there is only
one sentence that can be passed that is
a mandatory life sentence
let there be no misunderstanding about
this
the sentence will be one of life
imprisonment
that means that the defendant may spend
the rest of his days in prison
however for reasons I shall explain this
is not a case which requires a whole
life order
I must therefore specify the minimum
term which must elapse before the
defendant can apply to be released on
license
that is the shortest period that he will
be required to serve in prison
there is no guarantee that he will in
fact be released at that stage
that will be a matter for the parole
board
I will specify sentences for the other
offenses but they will be served
concurrently with the sentence for
murder which will reflect the totality
of the offending
Corbell is an offense that shocked not
only the city of Liverpool but the
nation
Olivia's name is likely to be remembered
for many years
she should not be remembered only for
her Dreadful last moments
her family have spoken today of Olivia
in life
and of the hopes and dreams for her
future which was so cruelly snatched
away
it is plain that Olivia was a lovely
little girl who cared for others and
brightened the lives of her family and
friends
they have suffered an unimaginable loss
which they must carry for the rest of
their lives
nothing I say or do today will ease that
but they should know that they have my
sympathy
the mental scars from that night will
persist forever
Cheryl Corbell must also bear the
physical scars on her wrist and hand
she must have suffered terrible pain as
the bullet passed through her body
but her bravery and strength is obvious
she had fought to keep the trouble
outside and she ignored the pain as she
desperately tried to save Olivia
the need for her to receive emergency
treatment meant that she could not be
with her daughter when she died
nobody suggests that the defendant
intended to kill Olivia or to harm
Cheryl
that even if he did not know Olivia was
in the firing line the same cannot be
said about Cheryl
she opened her door and stepped outside
to see what was happening she
immediately recognized the gravity of
the situation and hurried back to get
inside and secure her home
it will have been apparent to the
defendant that she was not connected
with Joseph knee and was trying to keep
him out
he knew therefore that a holy innocent
woman was by the door and yet that is
where he chose to take aim
had he paused to think for one moment it
would have been obvious that this was a
family home and that others perhaps
including children were at risk
but the defendant was focused only on
the murder of Joseph knee and no one
else mattered to him
precisely what lay behind the attempt on
Joseph knee's life has not emerged the
court did not hear from him and the
defendant was certainly not willing to
share the truth
on his own evidence the defendant led a
criminal lifestyle in the course of
which he was prepared to use threats and
violence
Mr knee was a man with enemies who had
been shot up previously
that provides the context for what's
happened
whatever Mr knee may have done it
plainly did not justify the attempt on
his life
he suffered serious injuries and is
lucky to be alive
after things went so tragically wrong
the defendant went to the home of the
woman who was brave enough to come to
court to give evidence against him
I have made an order granting her
lifelong anonymity and will not name her
now
her evidence was significant as they
both realized
she chose to do the right thing
the defendant invented a defense
designed to humiliate and undermine her
it did not work
she was subjected to lengthy questioning
about the most intimate details that she
stood firm
I am sorry that she had to endure that
but endure it she did and her courage is
to be applauded
in sentencing for the murder of Olivia
Pratt Corbell I must follow the
statutory Provisions set out in schedule
21 of the sentencing Act 2020.
paragraph 2 2 ba of schedule 21 provides
that the starting point for the murder
of a child involving a substantial
degree of planning or promote meditation
is a whole life order
I have considered whether that applies
to this case but have concluded it does
not because the planning and
premeditation was not directed at the
child
there is no doubt though that the
seriousness of the murder
taken in combination with the other
offenses is particularly grave such as
to require a lengthy minimum term
the starting point for any murder
involving a firearm is 30 years as set
out in paragraph three of schedule 21.
I must then consider the aggravating and
mitigating factors set out in paragraphs
nine and ten together with any other
relevant circumstances
there can be no doubt that this shooting
involved a significant degree of
planning and premeditation
I bear in mind that many if not most
murders involving Firearms involves some
premeditation and that is already
accounted for in the starting point
the evidence in this case demonstrates
planning going well beyond that
the defendant had sourced two guns
presumably to allow for the possibility
of one misfiring
he knew what van Joseph knee was driving
and I am sure that he was looking out
for him earlier that day
having spotted his van he changed his
clothes and concealed his face before
heading towards him
only to realize that Mr knee had left
later having seen the van again and
realizing Mr knee was likely to remain
where he was until the end of the
televised football
the defendant again changed his clothes
got into position and lay in wait
this was a targeted planned execution
attempt
it commenced in a residential street
even as Mr knee ran for his life the
defendant ruthlessly pursued him
he then fired more shots as Mr knee
tried to take cover in a determined
effort to complete what he had set out
to do
it is accepted on the defendant's behalf
that Olivia was a particularly
vulnerable victim because of her age
I do not necessarily agree that Olivia's
age made her more vulnerable to being
killed in these specific circumstances
but it is academic to debate whether the
case comes within paragraph 9 B
the real gravity of this case is that a
young child was shot and killed in her
own home
as children do Olivia was coming
downstairs to seek reassurance
Cheryl Corbell should have been able to
give that reassurance and to took Olivia
back into bed
what's happened instead was chilling and
strikes fear not only into the immediate
Community but also into the minds of
other children and their parents
shooting into a family home with no
regard for who may be caught in the
crossfire is obviously a very
significant aggravating factor which
must be reflected in the minimum term
none of the statutory mitigating factors
apply in this case
while right that there was no intent to
kill Olivia the Fatal shot was fired
with the clearest possible intent to
kill
and I have determined that the shooting
was premeditated
the fact that the intent was directed
towards Joseph knee offers no mitigation
had the defendant plan to kill Olivia he
would have been facing a whole life
order
even had the defendant killed Joseph
knee rather than Olivia the premeditated
nature of the killing the use of two
firearms and the firing of shots into a
family home would still have required a
substantial uplift
at least it was Olivia who died
undoubtedly makes the offense more
serious still
further I am not considering this
offense in isolation the defendant must
also be sentenced for the other offenses
I shall take care not to double count
features that are common to counts one
to three
I am very conscious that the shot that
killed Olivia was one of those aimed at
Joseph knee while attempting to kill him
and was the same shot that wounded
Cheryl Corbell
however I must reflect the fact that the
harm caused was not limited to killing
Olivia but also included Serious injury
to two other people
had I been sentencing the defendant for
the attempted murder of Joseph knee
alone I would have imposed a life
sentence because of the obvious risk of
serious harm he poses to members of the
public
I agree with the submissions that this
is a category A2 case within the
relevant sentencing guideline
that gives a starting point of a
determinant sentence of 30 years and a
range of 25 to 35 years
even in the context of a category a case
the offense is aggravated by the
planning the Relentless pursuit of Mr
knee and the use of two firearms so I
will select select a figure towards the
upper end of the range
in setting the minimum term to be served
on a discretionary life sentence the
notional term should be discounted by
one-third to reflect the early release
Provisions which apply to a determinant
sentence
I need not dwell further on the minimum
term for count two since it will make no
practical difference to the minimum term
which must be served which will be that
imposed on count one
for count three wounding Cheryl Corbell
with intent to do Grievous bodily harm
to another the offense falls into
category A2 in the relevant guideline
giving a starting point of seven years
imprisonment and a range of six to ten
years
the offense is aggravated by being
committed against a woman in her own
home and I consider this a sentence at
the top of that range is appropriate
Firearms offenses charged as counts four
and five are part and parcel of the
other offenses
it will be wholly artificial to consider
the appropriate sentence for these two
offenses had they stood alone
they are category A1 offenses within the
relevant guideline
the sentences on these counts will not
impact on the overall term the defendant
must serve it is therefore unnecessary
to say more and I will simply adopt the
starting point suggested by the
guideline namely 18 years imprisonment
I have explained the approach to the
sentences for the individual offenses
only said that the defendant and others
know how I have arrived at the eventual
sentence which I impose
the reality is that the defendants
offending cannot be compartmentalized
and the minimum term to be served will
reflect the totality of his offending
the defendant murdered Olivia Pratt
Corbell a young child in her own home
he did so in the course of attempting to
murder Joseph knee as part of a planned
and sustained attack involving the use
of two firearms
he caused serious injuries to Mr knee
and came close to killing him
he also shot Cheryl Corbell causing her
significant physical injury to say
nothing of the psychological scars he
caused her and others that is the basis
on which he will be sentenced
the defendant is now aged 34 he is not
of previous good character
any attempt to rely on an absence of any
significant History of Violence has to
be viewed in the context of what he told
the jury
he made it quite clear that he was a
criminal who used threats and violence
when it suited him
although I will not treat that as
aggravation there is no mitigation to be
found in his history
the defendant has not acknowledged his
responsibility for Olivia's death and so
has demonstrated no remorse
his failure to come into court is
perhaps further evidence of that
although I make it clear that this has
not caused me to increase his sentence
the defendant is a father and I accept
that being taken away from his children
is a loss for him and for them
it is a loss that he is wholly
responsible for
there is in my judgment no real
litigation available to the defendant
I Now Pronounce the sentence
on count one for the murder of Olivia
Pratt Corbell the sentence will be life
imprisonment
the minimum term will be 42 years less
the time the defendant has already spent
on remand
on count two the attempted murder of
Joseph knee the sentence is life
imprisonment with a minimum term of 22
years
on count three wounding Cheryl Corbell
with intent to do Grievous Bosley harm
to another the sentence is 10 years
imprisonment
on counts four and five the Firearms
offenses the sentence is 18 years
imprisonment on each
all those sentences are to be served
concurrently meaning that the shortest
period the defendant will be required to
serve before he can be considered for
early release from the sentence of life
imprisonment is 42 years less the 182
days he has served on remand
after he has served that minimum term he
can only be released if the parole board
decide that is appropriate
he would then remain on license for the
remainder of his life
the statutory surcharge will be added to
the record
thank you that that completes my
sentencing remarks and it completes the
sentencing hearing
oh well there you have it the sentencing
of Thomas Cashman for the murder of
nine-year-old Olivia Pratt Corbell it is
a life sentence with a minimum of
42 years it is 42 years until he can
apply for parole let's bring in our
crime correspondent Martin brunt who is
outside Manchester Crown Court for us
and Martin there were cheers outside the
court there as the news came out about
that sentencing
yes I mean I'm not quite clear who was
cheering but clearly supporters of of
Olivia's uh family who've just heard the
news relayed from inside Court
um of course it's it's a it's a tiny
court and there's very little room for
any members of the public so news is
filtering out uh within seconds of it of
it happening yes 42 years
um that's a huge minimum sentence and
the judge making it clear that she had
considered the possibility of giving
Cashman a whole life sentence but um
decided not to
um because she had to accept that he had
not intended to kill Olivia
a whole life sentence she might have
given to him for the premeditated murder
of a gun murder of a child but it was
clear to everybody throughout the
hearing that his Target was somebody
else he was chasing another criminal
Joseph knee and had intended to kill him
so the judge making it very clear that
it was a fine line but she did give him
if you like the benefit of the doubt so
he's got a minimum 42 years which means
that he will be 76
before he's got any chance of being
released that will be his first
opportunity to ask for parole and I
guess a lot of people might think that
perhaps effectively
that is a whole life sentence and she
did make it clear as judges always do in
these circumstances that even at the end
of 42 years uh there would be no
guarantee that he would be freed she
summed it up towards the end
um saying that this is why she was
giving him uh the sentence she then
delivered that it was the murder of a
young child in her own home while he was
trying to kill somebody else and he
indeed as part of that crime he shot
Olivia's mother causing her a
significant injury and of course causing
psychological
scars to other people in the house and
to others outside of the house she said
he hadn't acknowledged his
responsibility
so there could be no remorse she said
he's a father and she acknowledged that
he would be separated from his own
family but that she said was all his
doing
a mark of what happens now Thomas
Cashman as we've been telling our
viewers wasn't in court today the
reasons behind that were apparently
connected to staff from the CPS uh
singing after his guilty verdict last
week and reminders of the circumstances
about why he wasn't in court and what's
going to happen to him now
well yeah the um the whole thing was
held up for about 40 minutes this
afternoon and it began to filter down
that he was refusing to appear in court
and there's nothing the judge can do
about that she reluctantly had to accept
it and the reason we understand is that
he became aware that on his conviction
last week
somebody within the crown prosecution
service or a number of people perhaps
were singing We Are the Champions um the
famous Queen song A much celebrated
anthem on many many different occasions
we don't know whether he was that was
something he claimed to have witnessed
himself but he made it clear to his
lawyer that that had upset him he also
said to his lawyer that the whole
proceedings in his view were turning
into a circus and on that basis he
refused to appear in court I mean he'd
been brought here many hours ago from
prison in Manchester so everybody
anticipated that he would appear in
court but he didn't and that was the
reason given and the judge having to say
say that she accepted that but she did
say that she found that disrespectful to
her and her court but more importantly
disrespectful to Olivia's family
he will now be taken back to prison and
at some stage will probably be moved to
another prison where he'll begin the
start of that very very long sentence I
I can't remember anybody other than
convicted terrorists being given that
kind of minimum sentence 42 years
it's just gone at four o'clock you're
watching Sky News if you are just
joining us Thomas Cashman has just been
given a life sentence with a minimum
term of 42 years for the murder of
nine-year-old Olivia Pratt Corbell in
Liverpool uh judge Mrs yesters yet
Justice Yip said that the planned murder
of a child requires a whole life term
but that is not applicable here as the
planning and pre-meditation was not
directed at the Char but she said the
crime remained particularly grave and
chilling she went on in her sentencing
remarks to explain
um the terms of the five counts that
Thomas Cashman was found guilty of last
week including the murder of Olivia
Pratt Corbell uh all the sentences are
going to run concurrently with the
murder sentence all of the sentences
reflected in the totality of the
sentence which as we have just found out
within the last few minutes is a life
sentence with a minimum term of 42 years
our crime correspondent Martin brunt has
been following events at Manchester
Crown Court he is outside the building
for us now and Martin it's been
well the most unimaginable time for the
family and friends of young Olivia they
have been in court every day they
delivered their family impact statements
in that courtroom today that I'm sure
they had hoped to deliver directly to
Thomas Cashman the man responsible for
young Olivia's murder that wasn't to be
as he refused uh to be in attendance
today but we understand that they will
be speaking outside Court a little later
as well
foreign
we're expecting to hear from Olivia's
aunts we may hear from Olivia's mother
and of course we'll hear from the police
and the crown prosecutors yes they may
feel they were deprived of something
important by Thomas cashman's refusal to
go into court nevertheless those
statements and very moving they were
were delivered the first came from John
Pratt who is Elizabeth Olivia's father
he talked about seeing his daughter the
day before she was murdered
um
he talked about how life has been so
difficult for him since her murder he
couldn't cope with a media coverage had
to leave Liverpool he talked about
sitting outside the cemetery where
Olivia is buried to um to be close to
her he talked about
Olivia being deprived of her future but
also
he and Olivia being deprived of that one
big thing that all fathers look forward
to with with daughters walking their
daughter down the aisle on their wedding
day
um he said that will never happen
um we then heard from Olivia's older
sister Chloe she read her statement
um tearful at times but she talked about
when Olivia was born she was eight years
older than Olivia that that was a day
that she received her best ever present
she was her baby sister but they became
good friends and she too talked about
what she and Olivia have lost together
by Olivia's death they'll never go
shopping together she said they'll never
be able to confide in each other when
they've got things to share private
things to share then we heard from
Olivia's mother Cheryl she too read her
statement and she referred throughout
not to Olivia but to live the name that
she knew her daughter by she too was
sometimes tearful she talked about how
every day at around 2 30 was a very
difficult time for her that hadn't
changed since Olivia's death that was
school pickup time she said when she
would go and collect Olivia from school
we'll never be able to do that together
she said one of the very moving points
she made was that because she was
injured
by the bullet that killed Olivia
remember the bullet went through the
door and then threw Cheryl
Cheryl corbell's hand she was unable to
give Olivia the life-saving treatment
that she wanted to so desperately she
couldn't give her CPR she said because
she was badly injured and it was um she
had to wait for a neighbor to come in to
uh to make an attempt to keep Olivia
alive she said
um she also talked about her own mother
Olivia's Nan who had been seriously ill
recently in fact was terminally ill and
had been brought home for end of life
care but she said remarkably she managed
to hold on
uh throughout the trial she was still
alive when the verdicts were delivered
last Thursday and said Cheryl Corbell
her mother died last night that was a
very moving moment and then we began to
hear from the judge and the judge began
by saying that she had considered a
whole life
sentence without hope of parole for
Cashman but then outlined the reasons
why she hadn't and principally it was
because and the judge had to accept this
Cashman hadn't intended to kill Olivia
he had intended to kill the man he was
chasing and the man he shot and in fact
the bullet that he fired at the man he
was trying to kill was the bullet that
killed Olivia so perhaps to all intents
and purposes the intent was transferred
the intent to kill was transferred from
his Target to Olivia and I think that
more than anything
was born out by that very long sentence
minimum sentence of 42 years before
Cashman will even get the chance of
asking for parole and as the judge made
clear even at that stage when he served
42 years in prison
and he'll be then by then 76 there'll be
no guarantee of Freedom perhaps to all
intents and purposes this is a whole
life sentence for Thomas Cashman
I would just to remind you of the
breaking news Thomas Cashman the man
found guilty of the murder of a young
Olivia Pratt Corbell just nine at the
time of her death has this afternoon
been sentenced to life imprisonment with
a minimum term of 42 years we are
awaiting for statements to be delivered
outside Manchester Crown Court from
family members as well as from
merseyside police and the crown
prosecution service after the sentence
uh the sentencing this afternoon and
Martin I just want to talk a little bit
more about the judge's sentencing
remarks in which she you know talked
about The Bravery of not just Olivia's
family but also the key witness in this
trial of women who was granted anonymity
and will now you know be in a witness
protection program presumably for for
most of her her life after giving
evidence against Thomas Cashman and that
was seen as a as the key evidence in
this trial because because of course
it's worth reminding you is that Thomas
Cashman has not admitted guilt
throughout this entire process therefore
has shown no remorse
um no can I just correct something I
talked about the elderly family member
who died it was Cheryl's Nan so it was
Olivia's Great Nan who died last night I
said originally it was Olivia's
grandmother so we should make that clear
yes you were asking me I think about the
witness the main witness in this case
who was a woman
who we can't identify she's been granted
anonymity for life
she was the main prosecution witness and
she told this compelling story about how
Cashman who claimed he wasn't the gunman
how Cashman had turned up at her house
within minutes of the shooting
in a bit of a state wanting a change of
clothes and then talking to her partner
Paul Russell a little bit later on and
the woman saying she clearly overheard
Cashman saying I've done Joey which the
pro she and the prosecution said was a
reference to his shooting of Joseph knee
in the moments before he fired the final
Bullet at Joseph knee the bullet that
killed Olivia the judge talked about her
exceptional bravery how she wasn't
shaken under pretty rigorous cross
examination by the defense I mean I I
didn't listen to those exchanges but
colleagues who did said so it got very
fiery she was a very spirited witness
and stuck to her story and that more
than anything perhaps was what convinced
the jury of Thomas cashman's guilt now
she that witness talked during her
evidence about her whole life had now
been ruined her Children's Life had been
ruined and although we don't know for
certain I think it's likely that she is
somebody who will at least be offered
witness protection of some degree which
might mean
spending the whole of her life away from
her family and friends but clearly she's
been granted
lifelong anonymity and whatever the
circumstances of her life from now on
they are going to be markedly different
to what they were but the judge paying
tribute to that woman as a very brave
Witness
but it's worth just reminding everybody
what happened during the sentencing not
just the remarks but the breakdown of
the sentencing as well because of course
the headline is that life sentence with
a minimum of 42 years for the murder of
Olivia Pratt called Bell but Thomas
Cashman was found guilty on a number of
other counts and the sentences that were
handed down for those are going to run
concurrently perhaps you could break
them down for us
yeah so 40 life for the murder of Olivia
and a minimum sentence of 42 years
at that stage he'll get his first
opportunity
um to ask for parole
um less 180 days which is the time he
spent uh in custody which I guess
effectively is neither here nor there
for the second conviction of attempted
murder of Joseph knee the man he was
chasing and trying to shoot trying to
kill he got again life imprisonment but
a minimum sentence of 22 years the third
crime he was convicted of was wounding
with intent to cause Grievous bodily
harm that's for the shooting of Olivia's
mum Cheryl he got 10 years minimum
sentence or sorry 10 years for that and
for the final two crimes of possessing a
firearm remember there were two guns
used in this um in this murder he was
given 18 years for each of those each of
those crimes but the judge making it
clear that she had taken into account in
deciding that that minimum 42 years
for the murder of Olivia that that did
include the use of guns so um I suppose
she might have let some of those
sentences run consecutively but she made
it clear early on that um that that they
would be concurrent so that's the
breakdown of the sentences two life
sentences
um a 10-year sentence and to 18-year
sentences all rolled into one a minimum
of 42 years in prison
and Martin just referring back to the
sentencing remarks when the judge was
explaining these sentences it's
fascinating to watch live for our
viewers to see that just to you know
because often we just deliver the
sentences in these big trials and people
wonder how the judges come to that
particular decision that particular
amount of time and in this case in the
case of Thomas Cashman a lot of the
decision-making was centered around
pre-meditation or planning
yes the defense tried to argue and um
you know it's a difficult job for the
defending Barrister given everything
that's happened um in in the last few
days the convictions and um you know the
outrage
over this murder
um he did try to argue that the level of
planning wasn't substantial it also
argued and was almost apologetic in the
way he put this he also argued that um
that Cashman hadn't intended to kill
Olivia well the judge jumped in pretty
quickly and said well he did intend to
kill Joseph knee and the point wasn't
lost although she didn't make it
absolutely clear that the bullet he
fired at Joseph knee was the bullet that
killed Olivia so
um
yes so um forgotten what you asked me
sorry
it's a complicated matter there are so
many sentences that have come in and
there is so much information about this
trial and this came smart and it was
fine I was just talking about how the um
sentence how the judge decides on this
sentence in the remarks that's where
it's laid out clear so it's important
for us to show it to the public and her
decision in this case was centered
around premeditation and planning that's
what she took into consideration when
she came up with the sentences
yes I mean she she disagreed with the
defense which said that there wasn't a
substantial amount of planning she
thought that there was and she said the
very fact that he took two guns with him
um presumably in case one jammed uh that
showed a degree of planning
um he had worked out the van that his
Target Joseph knee uh would be driving
um and was looking out for him remember
a big part of the prosecution case was
that Joe Cashman had been scoping Joseph
knee looking for him uh for several
hours on the day that he eventually shot
him walking past the house where he
thought he would be looking for his van
um changing his clothes she said that he
changed his clothes twice during the day
and at one point obscuring his face
remember some of those CCTV images of
Thomas Cashman
um showed him wearing a hoodie a hoodie
up sometimes because it was raining but
other times when it already stopped
raining but he was still
wearing something that obscured his face
and he lay in weight for more than half
an hour or so said the judge having
established that he'd found Joseph knees
van assuming that Josephine was in the
house where he was expecting him to be
watching football that night he lay in
weight for him so and then ruthlessly
pursued him down the road firing several
bullets at him
so on that basis the judge felt there
was a substantial degree of planning and
premeditation
but more than anything she said the
aggravating Factor was that he had
killed a person
of Olivia's age
and but for the fact that it she hadn't
been his main target
he she would have considered giving him
a whole life sentence in which he would
never be able to ask for parole
and Martin emotion running high in this
case and this trial and you know just
looking at nine-year-old Olivia and what
her family are going through is easy to
understand why but emotion doesn't have
a bearing on sentencing but the judge
did reference it in her sentencing
remarks saying that Olivia's death has
shocked not only the city of Liverpool
but the nation Olivia's name is likely
to remember be remembered for many years
she should not be remembered only for
her Dreadful last moments
yes I mean I the judge made it clear
when at the start of the trial when the
jury were listening to the videoed
evidence of Olivia's mum that they
shouldn't
um however difficult they found it they
shouldn't be swayed by emotion in coming
to their uh decision
um their verdicts um but I think it's
quite different for the judge
um I mean that's perhaps some of the
point of the impact statements
um that were read out by her Olivia's
closest family
um that the judge would take into
consideration the effect it's had on the
family and you know it was it was made
very clear by
Cheryl Olivia's mum and her father and
her elder sister Chloe that they felt
that not only had Olivia been robbed of
her life and her future
They too had been robbed of their life
with Olivia and I think that must have
played some part in the judge's
determination of the sentence but she
did talk about
unimaginable loss and the mental scars
that will last forever among her family
and and perhaps other people so
I think the Judge did very much take on
board in her sentencing the impact
on the family she talked herself about
how clearly Olivia was a was a lovely
girl who cared for others and that was
something that her mother made clear in
her statement that she was much loved
but she was a very caring young girl who
thought of others
thank you
we are waiting uh Martin for some
statements uh following this sentencing
we are expecting to hear from Olivia's
family we are told to expect Olivia's
Aunt Louise Pratt to give a statement
and perhaps if she's feeling up to it
because you can't even begin to imagine
what she has been through today and over
the last few months Cheryl Corbell
Olivia's mother may well say a few words
as well we are also expecting merseyside
police and the crown prosecution service
um
we don't want to prejudge what the
family are going to say uh Martin but
merseyside police and the cbps what can
we expect from them after this
sentencing
well I I mean we've already heard
something
um from the police but um I think they
will want to reflect on the sentence
um and I'm sure certainly from police
and the crown prosecution service they
will and again without preempting what
they're going to say but they I'm sure
will hope that such a long sentence will
act as some kind of deterrent
um and you know Liverpool merseyside is
an area that wrestles
uh with a lot of gun crime a lot of
violence
um although there were signs in the last
two years that the number of guns fired
uh each year was coming down in fact
last year or the year before there was a
record level uh low level of gun
discharges but then of course Olivia's
murder was the third of three in a week
last December last last August the third
gun murder in a week and there have been
two since so nobody's suggesting that
that gun crime has been eradicated far
from it in merseyside but the police
have been successful in limiting
um up until Olivia's death limiting the
number of guns uh being fired on the
street I'm sure they will both make the
point the police and the crown
prosecutors that they hope this sentence
will act as a deterrent and also a point
Point they've made in the past was that
the The Bravery of the witness the main
witness in the case coming forward they
too hope
um will that too they hope will be an
indication to the community that you can
come forward and give information to the
police and be protected and be granted
anonymity now we'll only know whether
that's going to work over the next
couple of years or so but certainly
that's what will be on their minds
hey Martin uh we'll take a slight pause
there if you're just joining us here on
Sky News we're reflecting on the
sentence handed day down today to Thomas
Cashman for the murder of Olivia Pratt
Corbell just nine years old when she was
shot by the man you see on your screen
there back in August he has been
sentenced to life in prison this
afternoon with a minimum minimum of 42
years so he will be in his 70s when he
is eligible for parole however the judge
was at Payne today to point out that
just because you apply for parole
doesn't mean it will be granted so that
is Thomas Cashman today sentenced for
the murder of Olivia Pratt called Bell
we can bring you the judge's sentencing
remarks the judge is Mrs Justice let's
listen him
the defendant has not acknowledged his
responsibility for Olivia's death and so
has demonstrated no remorse
his failure to come into court is
perhaps further evidence of that
although I make it clear that this has
not caused me to increase his sentence
the defendant is a father and I accept
that being taken away from his children
is a loss for him and for them it is a
loss that he is wholly responsible for
there is in my judgment no real
mitigation available to the defendant
I Now Pronounce the sentence
on count one for the murder of Olivia
Pratt Corbell the sentence will be life
imprisonment
the minimum term will be 42 years less
the time the defendant has already spent
on remand
on count two the attempted murder of
Joseph knee the sentence is life
imprisonment with a minimum term of 22
years
on count three wounding Cheryl Corbell
with intent to do Grievous Bosley harm
to another the sentence is 10 years
imprisonment
on counts four and five the Firearms
offenses the sentence is 18 years
imprisonment on each
all those sentences are to be served
concurrently meaning that the shortest
period the defendant will be required to
serve before he can be considered for
early release from the sentence of life
imprisonment is 42 years less the 182
days he has served on remand
after he has served that minimum term he
can only be released if the parole board
decide that is appropriate
the judge there with her sentencing
remarks a little earlier on this
afternoon she handed down that life
sentence with a minimum term of 42 years
to Thomas Cashman uh well before those
sentencing remarks the courtroom heard
from members of Olivia's family her mum
her dad and her older sister and our
crime correspondent Martin brunt is
outside Manchester Crown Court for us
um
these impact statements Martin the
family had hoped to deliver them to
Thomas Cashman that's you know you hear
about those impacted by these horrendous
crimes they say that is their moment to
stand up in court and tell the person
who carried out the crimes against their
family members exactly what it has done
to their lives they were not given that
opportunity today because Thomas Cashman
refused to go into the courtroom but
these statements were so powerful
particularly Olivia's mum Martin I know
you've got some of it that you can bring
to us here now
thank you
yes they may feel they were deprived of
something by cashman's absence in court
but nevertheless they went ahead
um with with those statements and we
heard three the last of which was from
Olivia's mum uh Cheryl she read her own
statement and throughout it she referred
to Olivia as live obviously that was the
name that she always called her she was
sometimes tearful she choked on a couple
of occasions
and and she moved around in in her
thoughts um one of the early things she
said was that how she finds it very
difficult at 2 30 each day which was the
time she used to go and pick up Olivia
from school school pickup time she said
we'll never do that again
a couple of other things that that
sprang out very movingly she talked
about
at the time Olivia was shot she too had
been shot by the same bullet the bullet
that had gone through
her front door the family's front door
into her hand and caused her a serious
injury but it meant she said that at the
moment where she should have been trying
to save her daughter's life she couldn't
do CPR on her because of the injury to
her hand
her own she said that her neighbor had
had to come into the house and perform
CPR on Olivia but she felt awful that
she wasn't in a position to do that
herself another very moving moment
um Cheryl talked about her grandmother
Nan who'd been very seriously ill in
fact have been moved home for end of
Life Care was dying
throughout the trial had clung on
according to Cheryl Corbell and had
clung onto life up until the point of
the verdicts it was as though she was
hanging on said said Cheryl Corbell and
then she said that her grandmother
Olivia's great-grandmother Nan had died
last night
um
a very very sad moment for the whole
family but clearly Cheryl caulbell
feeling that they gained something
from her grandmother clinging to life
and hearing that Justice had been
achieved last Thursday with those
verdicts of guilty against Thomas
Cashman we heard from Chloe Olivia's
sister
to she read her statement out teenager
Chloe
she described Olivia's birth
and Chloe was is eight years older uh
than Olivia she talked about her birth
being the best present she'd ever had
when Olivia was born she said she was
her baby sister but they became good
friends
um she talked about what Olivia and she
have been deprived of as close sisters
that they'll never go shopping together
they'll never confide in each other like
sisters siblings do over secrets
so again
talking about the great loss of life to
Olivia but also what as family members
they would lose lose together with
Olivia's murder
um the first statement was read out by
the prosecutor and that came from
Olivia's dad John Pratt
um he talked several times about being
heartbroken he recounted the last time
he saw Olivia having been deprived of a
lot of contact with her during the
pandemic he was beginning to see her
again
he and Olivia's mother are separated but
he he recounted the last meeting the day
before she died
and talked about the conversation that
sometimes daughters and fathers have and
Olivia saying to him did you have a say
a shave especially to see me and him
telling her that yes he had had a shave
just to see his daughter he couldn't
cope with the local media people coming
up to him and asking about Olivia he
said so much so that he'd had to move
out of Liverpool he talked also movingly
about having how he spent time sitting
outside the cemetery where he could be
close close to his daughter and again
like
Olivia's mother and Olivia's sister he
talked about Olivia being deprived of
her future and something that you know
All fathers look forward to the fathers
of daughters look forward to walking
their daughters down the aisle
on their wedding day he said that was
something that he'll never be able to do
so moving words from Olivia's father one
of three impact statements very moving
impact statements delivered in the court
but without the presence of Thomas
Cashman who refused to be there
oh that family have endured so much if
they have been so brave today
um Martin
um thank you you can see our camera
there trained on the door
of Manchester Crown Court that is
because we are expecting uh statements
from members of Olivia's family we are
expecting her Aunt Louise Pratt
um to deliver some words on behalf of
the family following the sentencing
today of Thomas Cashman to life in
prison with a minimum term of 42 years
we are also expecting to hear from
Olivia's mum Cheryl Corbell who has
arrived at court every day of this trial
and again today clutching a teddy bear
made out of little Olivia's pajamas it's
almost oh gosh it's always too much bear
is there and we are expecting to hear
from her mum and merseyside police as
well will deliver a statement alongside
um the senior Crown prosecutor from the
crown prosecution service
um Martin I say family members are
hoping to deliver words I mean you know
Olivia's mom may do that but you know
given everything this family's been
through it depends on you know as she
walked into court she said she didn't
know how to feel today I'm not sure how
she'll feel after that sentence some
kind of Justice hopefully but it's
emergency by police in the crown
prosecution service we will be hearing
from them and what are they likely to
reflect on after today's sentencing
Martin
I think they'll be delighted with the
length of the minimum sentence
um I can't remember anybody other than a
terrorist being given that kind of
minimum sentence
um 42 years Thomas Cashman will be 76
when he gets the first opportunity to
ask for parole and by no means will it
be guaranteed at that stage he'll still
have to prove that he's of no danger or
of little danger to the public and I
think the police and the prosecutors
will be delighted at the length of that
sentence I have no idea what they were
expecting but I think all of us who
followed this were probably expecting
something in the high 30s but 42 years
may have broken
um you know a barrier in terms of
non-terrorist sentencing given that the
judge had already ruled out the
possibility of giving him a whole life
sentence I'm just getting a little bit
of detail of what happened in around the
time of that sentence being delivered
there were gasps from Olivia's family
and we talked about seeing Olivia's mum
and other members of the family coming
out here on Thursday just after those
guilty verdicts and you know for once
there were Smiles on Cheryl corbell's
face and remember she held up the pink
teddy bear the one that she's clutched
every day throughout this trial that she
said today in her statement she sleeps
with it's a teddy bear that was made out
of Olivia's pajamas and when she came
out on Thursday she held it up and sort
of cried out almost in a sense of
triumph over those guilty verdicts but
of course a Triumph set against the
continuing enormity she and the family
feel about the loss of Olivia we're
hoping that we'll hear from Cheryl call
Bill and we're told Corbell we're told
that we will hear
from from Olivia's aunt and of course we
will hear as we were saying from the
police and the CPS and I think one of
the points they'll want to emphasize
is that they hope this case has shown
that people can be brave within very
tight Community
um you know how how they deal how they
dealt in this case with that awful
conflict of outrage and a need for
justice but also loyalty to within the
community and the fear of giving
information to the police I'm sure the
police and CPS
do feel I know they feel this that this
case has shown
that people can come forward and in
their words do the right thing and they
hope that perhaps a long long sentence
like this 42 years for Thomas Cashman
will add to that sense that um
that people will feel confident that
things can get done if they come forward
and give police information and people
ruthless Killers like Thomas Cashman
will go to prison for a very long time
perhaps for the rest of his life
okay Martin
I'm just because we are hoping to hear
from merseyside police as Martin said
the senior investigating officer on
Olivia's murder spoke to Sky News about
the case and he said it was unlike
anything he'd encountered in his nearly
30-year police career
I'm pleased we got Justice for them
after all this uh length of time
and I mentioned before the dignity they
show through the course of the trial
particularly Shadow having to relive the
instance again
must have been
unbelievable I I will never know when
nor will any member of the investigation
team what she had to go through
um and that's the same for father as
well Dad's young the paired of them
we'll never understand exactly what
they've gone through and nor should we
even try
I've been police nearly 30 years and so
with colleagues
probably never been involved with
anything quite like that if I'm going to
be honest the circumstances around it
were just
at boldens and she was cowering behind
them all because she was scared in her
own home
he always feel as though you're safe in
your own house
I okay let's go to Manchester Crown
Court Louise Pratt Olivia's Aunt
delivering a statement after the
sentencing of Thomas Cashman today to
life in prison with a minimum term of 42
years she is alongside Olivia's dad John
Pratt
I make this statement on behalf of my
brother
Olivia's loving father John Francis
Pratt it was a completely heartbroken
his oldest her older sisters Casey and
Kelsey and the rest of the Pratt Family
following the conviction of Cashman and
his sentence today we'd like to say we
are happy with the outcome but we will
not be celebrating as nothing will fill
the Gap left in our lives following the
loss of Olivia
we would like to thank the jury for the
correct verdict and the witness who
showed courage and stood up for Olivia
give by giving evidence we listen to you
you would also like to thank Mr side
police and the officers from across the
country who assisted in the
investigation the legal team especially
Mr McLaughlin the hard way in getting
Justice for art Olivia
we would like to thank our flows Jamie
Justin and Nikki the sport they have
given my brother and family over the
hardest seven months of our lives our
thoughts are also with the families of
Sam Rich rimmer Ashley Dale
Jacqueline Russa
[Music]
[Applause]
and Ellie Edwards
we hope you get the Justice your loved
ones they deserve our greatest hope is
for this conviction to lead to more guns
and especially those used in the Mesa of
Olivia to be handed in to the police so
though no other families must go through
this tragedy lastly I would like to say
Olivia Pratt Corbell died a scared
nine-year-old and we hope Cashman is
haunted by this knowledge for the rest
of his life
thank you
powerful note to end that family
statement on they hope that the thoughts
of Thomas Cashman for the rest of his
life and that of a very scared
nine-year-old child that child of course
Olivia Pratt Corbell who came down the
stairs in her family home for Comfort or
after hearing the commotion created by
Thomas Cashman in his Pursuit Of A drugs
rival that went through her front door
and of course she was fatally wounded
Louise Pratt there saying that she hopes
that thought
haunts Thomas Cashman for the rest of
his life she gave that statement on
behalf of the family she said they are
happy but not celebrating
she thanked the jury the witness the
female witness who gave evidence against
Thomas Cashman and merseyside police
referring to our Olivia she said the
family have endured the hardest seven
months of Our Lives she referenced a
number of other families who are going
through
and equally harrowing ordeal including
the family of Ellie Edwards who you will
remember was shot on the Wirral on
Christmas Eve so they're generously um
giving their thoughts to those families
going through similar ordeals right now
let's bring in Martin brunt that is the
first statement of a number we are
expecting outside Manchester Crown Court
after today's sentencing Martin
yes we may get another three we're
certainly going to hear from the police
um Mark Baker the
um the investigating the senior
investigating officer who led uh the
team of detectives
um and we're going to hear from the
crown prosecution Service as well and we
may hear from Cheryl Corbell Olivia's
mother but yeah very moving statement
from Louise who talked about the
families
the family being heartbroken and made
the point and how difficult it must be
in these circumstances
um happy with the sentence but no
question of celebrating
um how could you when something like
this has happened nonetheless grateful
for that huge sentence of 42 years
minimum for Thomas Cashman and thanks as
we might have expected for
um
the witness particularly the main
witness who was brave enough to come
forward and give compelling evidence
against Thomas Cashman this wasn't the
greatest Gathering of prosecution
evidence
um
there was no direct forensic evidence
there were no weapons recovered there
were no eyewitnesses to the shooting and
certainly nobody who could identify
Thomas Cashman as the gunman nonetheless
people did come forward and give
evidence enough to put together a
prosecution case they're convinced the
jury of Thomas cashman's guilt so there
were thanks from Olivia's Aunt Louise
for the prosecution team she talked
about the hard work in getting getting
Justice for Olivia
and then she also said that their
thoughts were with the other murder
victims now remember that Olivia's
murder was the third in a week gun
murder last August and there have been
two more since so she referenced each of
those other gun murder victims from last
year and made the point that we've
talked about already today that they
hope that this will lead these Verde
makes this long sentence will lead to
more guns being handed into the police
more guns being taken off the streets of
of merseyside and a final Point talking
about how Olivia died a scared
nine-year-old and the family hoped that
Thomas Cashman is haunted by that idea
for the rest of his life
Martin for the moment thank you let's
bring you that statement in full from
Olivia's Aunt Louise Pratt speaking with
Olivia's Father John by her side
I make this statement on behalf of my
brother
Olivia's loving father John Francis
Pratt it was a completely heartbroken
the oldest her older sisters Casey and
Kelsey and the rest of the Pratt Family
following the conviction of Cashman and
his sentence today we'd like to say we
are happy with the outcome but we will
not be celebrating as nothing will fill
the Gap left in our lives following the
loss of Olivia
we would like to thank the jury for the
correct visit and the witness who showed
courage and stood up for Olivia goodbye
giving evidence we listen to you let's
take you back to Manchester Crown Court
Olivia's mother Cheryl Corbell coming
out to make a statement after the
sentence was handed down today to cut
Thomas Cashman a life sentence with a
minimum of 42 years his years
a very addictive guilty which has
confirmed our belief that Kashmir made
as our beautiful Olivia
Olivia was just beautiful with their
long brown hair
and big brown eyes
she was such a social butterfly she was
particularly good with the younger
children
I'm such a caring little girl
live was the life of Our Lives a sassy
chatty Gale who never ran out of energy
she was a character she was my baby and
she has amazing qualities and knew what
she wanted in life
everyone adored here she was the baby
off of our family on my little love my
shadow
now everything we do and everywhere we
go was a constant reminder that if she
is not there with us
all I promise for their future so
clearly taken away
we can now draw a line onto seven months
of agonizing torments that we had to
we have had to endure at the hands of
Cashman
justice has prevailed and I cannot begin
to express our relief I would like to
extend our sincere gratitude and thanks
to Mr McLaughlin and Mr Rising
the CPS all the investigation team and
police officers involved in work and
tires tirelessly to get this to court
my thanks go to the witnesses you
bravely assisted the prosecution case
and to fired the usual stance of people
do not grass
I was especially like to thank our
family liaison officers detective
Constable Louise Wright and Julie Moses
who've worked so hard and professionally
with boundless dedication to achieve
this result
we welcome the sentence given but what I
can say is that my family and I have
already started our life sentence having
to spend the rest of our lives without
Olivia
we are overwhelmed by the outstanding
support of the public during this
horrific time and wish to say thank you
we now ask for time and space to time
process what has happened to us over the
past few months and most importantly
gray Ferrara Olivia who was so cruelly
stolen from us
thank you
[Applause]
together
the mother of murdered nine-year-old
Olivia Pratt Corbell speaking outside
Manchester Crown Court there referring
to our beautiful Olivia describing some
of the wonderful qualities of that
little girl she was a social butterfly a
caring little girl and uh Cheryl there
describing her as the light of Our Lives
a little girl who knew what she wanted
in life she called her my little love my
shadow she said everything we do is now
a constant reminder that she is not
there she went on to talk about the
seven months of agonizing torment
for her family as she wanted to thank
the merseyside police the Witnesses in
the trial who she said defied the stance
that Witnesses do not grasp she said
that she welcomes the life sentence
today of Thomas catchman but says that
her family has already started their
life sentence of life without Olivia she
ended by asking that her family have the
time and space they need to grieve
I'm going to bring back in our crime
correspondent Martin brunt now
um Martin the emotion for the family of
Olivia is clear
we've heard from investigating police
officers in this case and the emotion
there is clear and also for the
community The Wider Community this is a
case that has really shaken Liverpool
merseyside and it's fair to say the
country as well
yes um we are told from the very few
number of colleagues who were in court
that the family were in tears at one
point when that sentence was high handed
down so I just have to interrupt you
with Martin I just have to interrupt you
I'm sorry the senior investigating
officer Mark Baker is now speaking of
the crime committed by Thomas Cashman
he now has a long time Behind Bars to
contemplate his actions
in fact he won't be out
for a very long time and you'll be an
old man when he is
we heard earlier from Shadow Chloe
and John of the devastating impact
her death has had on all the families
and friends
today's sentence will never bring Olivia
back
I again thank the witness who assisted
in bringing to Justice from Olivia's
family
she did the correct thing
and she should be proud of herself
the courage and bravery that she that
Olivia's family have shown is in direct
contrast to the cowardice shown by
Thomas Cashman
[Applause]
I hope that the sentence of 42 years
given to Thomas Cashman today will act
as a deterrence for anyone who thinks of
picking up a gun and putting our
communities at risk through their
Reckless Behavior
this has been a challenging complex and
emotional inquiry
I want to thank and praise the
commitments dedication and sheer
determination
of the investigation team as they
pursued the truth
I want to thank our prosecution
barristers Mr McLaughlin Mr riding
for Reserve special thanks for Maria
core
from the crown prosecution service for
her professionalism and the confidence
that she placed in our inquiry team and
her support through involved the
investigation
thank you thank you all
[Applause]
detective superintendent Mark Baker
there of merseyside police the senior
investigating officer in this case
um reflecting there on the lengthy
sentence handed down today to Thomas
Cashman a life sentence with a minimum
term of 42 years Mark Baker there saying
that he felt the long sentence was time
that Thomas Cashman would take to
contemplate his actions he said that the
sentence will never bring Olivia back he
not only commended The Bravery of the
Keen witness in this case the woman who
anonymously gave evidence against Thomas
Cashman he said she did the correct
thing and she'd be proud of herself he
also commended The Bravery of Olivia's
family which he said was in direct
contrast to what was shown by Thomas
Cashman who of course has not admitted
guilt nor shown remorse he said he hoped
the sentence handed down today will be a
deterrent to anyone thinking of picking
up a gun let's bring in our senior crime
correspondent Martin brunt who was
following that statement from outside
Court Martin
uh well very much as we expected
um thanks to the victim to The Bravery
of her but also to the courage of
Olivia's family but that very telling
point about hoping
that today's sentence will act as a
deterrent
um to anybody who's thinking of picking
up a garden and embarking on Reckless
Behavior
um
within merseyside
communities now you know we'll know
won't we in the next few months whether
it is having that effect and we've
spoken already about how Olivia's
murder was the third gun murder in a
week last August and there have been two
other gun murders since so there have
been some very very serious gun crimes
on merseyside last year two since
Olivia's murder although in the
preceding two or three years merseyside
police have been very successful in
reducing the number of gun discharges
nonetheless five gun murders within a
few months is a terrible indictment of
the level of gun crime in merseyside so
much as merseyside police can hope that
this will act as a deterrent and perhaps
more than the sentence it's the fact
that people were encouraged to come
forward and give police information
whether that does have the desired
effect
is it's going to be difficult to tell
and I remember being here in 2007 when
Reese Jones
a young Schoolboy was caught in similar
kind of circumstances caught by a
gangsters or a young gangster's bullet
and died how at that time people talked
about the need for change that enough is
enough and this was going to be a
watershed in the level of gun crime in
merseyside and of course it wasn't
and I spent some time last week with a
rather notorious figure a man who was a
gangster in Liverpool and he made that
point that you know although people are
full of good intentions at times like
this people do most people go back to
their lives carry on as before so much
as merseyside police hoped that this and
not just the police but the communities
hope that this will perhaps be a
watershed in gun crime it's difficult to
see that that is going to happen in the
way that people want it to
Martin thank you Martin brunt following
events outside Manchester Crown Court
for us we are waiting to hear from the
crown prosecution service they are
expected to deliver a statement outside
Manchester Crown Court the senior Crown
prosecutor will deliver those remarks
we'll bring them to you live here on Sky
News as and when they come in we have
heard
from Olivia's Aunt this afternoon
speaking outside that court on behalf of
the family standing alongside Olivia's
heartbroken Father John Pratt she said
that the family is happy today but not
celebrating she said this has been the
hardest seven months of Our Lives we
have also heard from Olivia's mum as
well Cheryl Corbell
um Olivia's Father John Pratt gave a
victim statement inside court and some
haunting words from him today he said
Olivia will never call me dad again she
will be forever nine and he talked about
sitting outside of the cemetery unable
to go in to visit Olivia because then it
would seem all too real those victim
statements read out in court today by
Olivia's Brave family members Thomas
Cashman not in attendance he refused to
attend in person for the sentencing and
to hear the impact of his actions on
Olivia's family let's listen now to
Olivia's mom Cheryl
on Thursday 30th of March 2023 my
vehicle The Addictive guilty which has
confirmed our belief that Cashman made
us our beautiful Olivia
Olivia was just beautiful with their
long brown hair
and big brown eyes she was such a social
butterfly she was particularly good with
the younger children and was such a
caring little girl
it was the life of Our Lives a sassy
chatty Gale who never ran out of energy
she was a character she was my baby and
she has amazing qualities and knew what
she wanted in life
she was the baby off of our family and
my little love my shadow
now everything we do and everywhere we
go was a constant reminder that if she
is not there with those
all I promise for their future so
cruelly taken away
we can now draw a line onto seven months
of agonize and torments that we had to
we have had to endure at the hands of
Cashman
justice has prevailed and I cannot begin
to express our relief
I would like to extend our sincere
gratitude and thanks to Mr McLaughlin
and Mr Rising
the CPS all the investigation team and
police officers involved in work and
tires tirelessly to get this to court
my thanks go to the witnesses who
bravely assisted the prosecution case
and defied the usual stance of people do
not grasp
I was especially like to thank our
family liaison officers detective
Constable Louise Wright and Julie Moses
who've worked so hard and professionally
with boundless dedication to achieve
this result
we welcome the sentence given but what I
can say is that my family and I have
already started our life sentence having
to spend the rest of our lives without
Olivia
we aren't overwhelmed by the outstanding
support of the public during this
horrific time and wish to say thank you
we now ask for time and space to time
process what has happened to us over the
past few months and most importantly
gray Ferrara Olivia who was so cruelly
stolen from us
thank you
it's just coming up to five o'clock
you're watching the NewsHour I'm Mark
Austin coming up in the next 60 Minutes
the man who murdered nine-year-old
Olivia Pratt Corbell is jailed for life
with a minimum term of 42 years
the judge accused Thomas Cashman of
disrespect for refusing to appear in
court to be sentenced
[Music]
and so has demonstrated no remorse
his failure to come into court is
perhaps further evidence of that
[Music]
also this evening former U.S president
Donald Trump prepares to travel to New
York to face criminal charges
he is expected to leave his Mar-A-Lago
Resort in Florida in the next few
minutes
he's unexpected to board his plane at
Palm Beach International Airport to take
the three-hour flight to New York City
there Mr Trump is expected to surrender
to prosecutors to face charges relating
to hush Money Paid to an adult film star
[Music]
also this evening Russia blames Ukraine
as it arrests a woman over the death of
a pro-military blogger at a cafe in
Saint Petersburg
and as NATO confirms Finland will join
the alliance tomorrow the Kremlin
pledges to boost its military capacity
[Music]
good evening and we're just going to
begin with these live pictures of Donald
Trump's Resort ma elago in Florida as I
was just saying he's about to leave to
head to New York as he becomes the first
American president or former American
president to face criminal sanctions
he's expected to meet New York
prosecutors tomorrow to face charges
relating to hush money payments made to
the adult movie star Stormy Daniels and
we'll bring you that a little piece of
History taking place in the United
States as it happens live
but first the man who killed
nine-year-old Olivia Pratt called Bell
in Liverpool last year has been jailed
for a minimum term of 42 years the judge
said Thomas Cashman had shown No Remorse
and refused to appear in court to be
sentenced he was convicted last week of
shooting Olivia dead as he fired shots
into her family home in dovecot while
pursuing another man last August
Hattie paused to think for one moment it
would have been obvious that this was a
family home and that others perhaps
including children were at risk